strong bipartisan eye vote yield back
the balance of my time in which everyone
a happy healthy and safe New Year happy
holidays Merry Christmas Happy schwanza
Happy Hanukkah whatever it is you
celebrate be safe
ever it is you celebrate this is the
Reuben report I'm Dave Rubin we are
rolling into 2023 we're live streaming
on Rumble and YouTube and
ones uh
I hope you guys had a great schwanza I
didn't ask you the other day when I saw
you for the first time in the New Year
how was your schwanza hope your schwanza
was great people uh we are going to be
doing a Reuben report.locals.com
Community Q a it's a great cross-section
of questions for uh I would say the the
start of the year and and how we're
going to frame things going forward and
it's a little all over the place which
is just the way I like it but what I
wanted to start with today was a little
bit about the sort of conspiracy
craziness that we are all in right now
that a whole bunch of us kind of saw
things a certain way saw through some of
the lies but the lies just keep coming
and the more that the conspiracy
theorists the conspiracy theorists I
should say uh point to some stuff the
more that the machine tries to discredit
those people but at this point I think
it is fairly obvious to most of us that
there is some level full of coordinated
effort by global actors is this crazy
stuff
to put in some sort of government in
charge of everybody and that we won't
really have States we will just have
this one giant machine telling us what
to do oh and by the way we won't have
anything but we'll be happy so uh so
let's get right into it uh first up
here's a tweet from an account called
covid1984. they noted that on the world
economic Forum website they've removed
Twitter from their how to follow page
now that might seem like sort of nothing
to you like Zippity Doo Dah except that
have you heard of this world's richest
man this Elon Musk guy well he bought
Twitter in case you've been living under
a rock uh he bought Twitter a couple
months ago and he has been releasing
these Twitter files which have of course
shown us information about the
suppression of the hunter Biden laptop
story which has shown us suppression of
counter narratives when it came to covid
and other Free Speech related things so
the idea that the world World economic
Forum which is the organization that is
ushering in this globalist government or
whatever it is okay uh that they don't
want people going on Twitter anymore in
essence right they're saying Twitter is
not a trusted source of news or of
information except Twitter is where
reality seems to be online right now
that's sort of ironic I suppose in light
of the last couple years of Twitter but
that really is what it is and because
Elon Musk has come in and basically said
hey I am for free speech I don't really
like journalists I want people to be
able to spread their message and and
find out truth and all of those things
the world economic Forum ain't happy
with them uh but we've got some receipts
of the world economic Forum trying to
censor people uh through Tech here is
some info from the daily wire this is
back in August but I think you'll see
why I'm talking about it now the world
economic Forum shared a report last week
outlining a plan to mitigate the Dark
World of online harm by using human and
artificial intelligence to censor Bad
actors who produce and promote child
abuse disinformation and hate speech
inval goldberger vice president of trust
and safety at active fence a company
that detects malicious online content
published an op-ed on the global
organization's website offering a
solution to online abuse such solutions
would enable a blend of AI and so-called
subject matter experts to detect nuanced
novel online abuses at scale before they
reach mainstream platforms goldberger
argues the online that online access has
placed placed a played a vital role in
public perception of events like
recessions viruses and Wars okay do you
get its people I think you do now first
off
on the child abuse part of this of
course if someone is spreading uh videos
or pictures related to child abuse or
something of that nature you've got a
problem with the government and that
obviously should be taken down by the
big tech companies and the government
should do whatever it has to do to to
take care of those people right to the
fullest extent of the law uh when it
comes to misinformation and
disinformation and hate speech this is
where it gets dangerous and this is
really to put this whole thing together
this is really where the United States
in many ways stands alone because of our
First Amendment right we cannot have
another organization that is above the
laws of the United States if the United
States is here we can't have anything
above that you'd have God above that but
you can't have anything else above that
right and what they are trying to do is
they are trying to create the world
economic Forum partnership so that they
will be able to look at hate speech and
misinformation but guess what from an
American perspective hate speech and
misinformation and disinformation are
your god-given right it's right there in
the Constitution Bill of Rights it's the
first one it's all there so they are
actively trying to infringe on your free
speech also I know it goes without
saying but here we are uh disinformation
and misinformation is mostly what the
machine has promoted it is mostly what
you've gotten out of CNN and the
Washington Post and New York Times and
all of these people so as I always say
they might just want to find a mirror as
opposed to censoring the rest of us but
speaking of censorship political
correctness and Global Climate activism
which is by the way what this is all
about because that's where the next
lockdowns are going to be coming because
I think people have had it with covid
lockdowns although a certain amount of
people like them the next one will be
we've got to lock you down because of
there's too much CO2 in the air
something interesting happened over the
Christmas break and I just wanted to
address it quickly because Andrew Tate
you know Andrew Tate kickboxing champion
who's become sort of a I don't want to
quite say a men's rights activist but
he's become a real voice for young men
to get their stuff together let's put it
that way Andrew Tate got into a little
Twitter squabble with Greta hunberg now
you all know Greta thundberg she is the
young lady who believes that the Earth
is going to end any minute now and has
become a hero of the machine and the
world economic forum and all of those
things uh they got into a little bit of
a Twitter spat so here is the tweet that
started this thing by Andrew Tate he
wrote hello Greta thundberg I have 33
cars my Bugatti has a quad turbo my two
Ferrari 812 competazion is that a word
have that's an Italian word I think have
v12s this is just the start please
provide your email address so I can send
a complete list of my car collection and
their respective enormous emissions now
he's obviously playing a bit of a troll
here he's throwing this at her like hey
I'm a dude producing something in the
world I've got a lot of stuff and he's
bragging about it and he doesn't want
her uh taking his cars uh Greta then
responded and said yes please do
enlighten me email me at small dick
energy at getalife.com and that got over
a million likes because people are what
they are anyway why am I telling you
about this a little spat between a
kickboxer and this little climate
activist well then uh two days later
bizarrely Andrew Tate was arrested in
Romania we've got a little video here
all right and for a little context on
that we've got more from the daily wire
American British media personality and
former kickboxer Andrew Tate and his
brother were detained in Romania in a
human trafficking investigation Thursday
along with a former policewoman
according to reports Romanian
authorities allegedly detained Tate and
his brother at their luxury Villa after
armed police raided his residence
searching for evidence related to the
case in which the brothers are accused
of abducting two women authorities
reportedly detained the two brothers for
24 hours Tates reported apprehension
comes after a day after he filmed a
video criticizing climate activist Greta
thundberg which included a pizza box
from a national chain in Romania Tate
faced allegations of human trafficking
in Romania in April 2022 however Tate
reportedly said the accusation stemmed
from a swatting incident where
authorities accused him and his brother
of obtaining large sums of money with
which they bought houses luxury cars and
cryptocurrencies according to reports
okay so I'm just piecing something
together here that I don't know exactly
what's going on here but it does strike
me as a little odd that this guy who is
becoming internet sensation gets into a
fight with the protected child of the
climate movement and then literally two
days later he is arrested in Romania
Greta thundberg was gloating about it on
the Twitter she said this is what
happens when you don't recycle your
pizza boxes now there was this rumor
that he was arrested purely because he
had sort of doxed himself because the
pizza chain is in Romania that rumor
flew like wildfire I mean it spread
crazy all over the internet turned out
not to be true of course in many many
mainstream people from NBC and elsewhere
were tweeting it but we thought it would
be funny to throw back to a little
something about Greta there is a way to
deal with Greta you don't have to show
off all your your cars to deal with
Greta you know the best way to deal with
Greta is you just ignore her cue Donald
Trump
thank you very much
how dare you
anyway speaking of climate activism
globalism and censorship uh let's shift
this to Bill Gates now you all know Bill
Gates Bill Gates created Microsoft Bill
Gray Gates created Windows which if
you're of a certain age you remember all
the pop-ups all the viruses you remember
my main memory of Windows Windows 95 is
the paint program you probably have to
paint program right and you could fill
the whole thing with the color and then
you could put other colors it was
incredible anyway he becomes a
billionaire now he owns more Farmland in
the United States than anyone else uh he
somehow also thinks he's a covet expert
and he has been advocating for more ESG
programs now ESG I'm going to tell you a
bit more about it in just a moment we've
talked about it before Glenn Beck wrote
a spectacular book about it's called
environmental social and government uh
programs in effect but here's Bill Gates
advocating for more ESG collaborations
we need to innovate to make the cost of
doing it the Greenway far less than it
is today to get emissions all the way to
zero not just the rich countries but the
entire world it's not so much who you
don't invest in it's who you do invest
in driving Innovation with some
incentives like the tax credits that the
US has now that's the right policy mix
we did get three bills that went through
Congress two were bipartisan one was a
Reconciliation Bill all of which
increased the funding for climate in
total about 500 billion extra dollars so
the combination of these new bills plus
private efforts like Breakthrough energy
Catalyst mean you're gonna you're gonna
get to go to a lot of plant openings
where people say okay this is green
steel this is green cement this is green
hydrogen and a lot of those will be
placed in places where the hydrocarbon
jobs are going away so people get a
sense that this is a a just transition
all right so let me be clear about one
thing which is that I really think the
Bill Gates is an evil person I I think
that the power and the money has gone to
his head where he thinks it is it is his
divine right to reorganize or rejigger
the world in a way that he wishes it to
be the idea not only first off that you
would say to any country but you take
okay let's take the rich countries first
because he addressed rich countries that
you would say you have to do this to
your economy you have to make it more
green because we wish you too well every
nation should decide that for themselves
that's the problem with globalization
right that's number one but putting
aside the rich countries the poor
countries right now that are going
through their industrial revolutions if
you take a country you could take India
or China that are years behind us in
their industrial revolutions that are
using coal and these other things what
right do we have or the globalists have
to say no you cannot do that and by the
way fossil fuels are still to this very
moment getting more people out of
poverty and doing more good for the
world than they are bad we've done many
shows on this Jordan Peterson has talked
about a lot Bjorn Lumberg uh this this
is something that is real whether they
like it or not so here's a bit more on
what ESG actually is this is from
Investopedia environmental social and
governance investing refers to a set of
standards for a company's Behavior used
by socially conscious investors to
screen potential Investments
environmental criteria consider how a
company safeguards the environment
including corporate policies like
addressing climate change for example
social criteria examine how it manages
relationships with employees suppliers
customers and the communities where it
operates governance deals with a
company's leadership executive pay
audits internal controls and shareholder
rights do you guys see how scary this is
a giant globalist organization wants all
of our corporations in rich countries
and poor countries and countries in the
middle to have to sit to have to use a
certain set of Standards when it comes
to hiring which of course will be
related to diversity of skin color and
sexuality I have nothing to do with
actual talents or intellectual diversity
they will want these companies to do
what they want them to do related to the
environment what they want them to do
related to any program that they want to
get across and then you can basically
install the world economic forum
can basically install CEOs in all of
these companies to do whatever they want
which often will be completely contrary
to what the company's mission is a shoe
company is supposed to make shoes
they're not supposed to be worried that
a giant globalist organization wants
them to hire a certain amount of black
disabled lesbians as lofty as that goal
might be right to make shoes okay
this is the problem with pretty much
everything right now and the reason that
I'm doing all of this today and then
we're going to get to the Q a in just a
second is that I really think that this
is the new thing that we're fighting
maybe we've been fighting it all along I
I suppose that we probably have and this
is all connected to covid and these
giant organizations that that tried to
destroy the known world uh that most of
us probably took for granted but it's
time to stop taking it for granted and
fight while we still can because
this is this is our one life people and
I don't want to be under the boot of
Bill Gates or any of these people I
don't like them very much and now to the
Reuben
report.locals.com Community Q a uh hope
says during my husband's childhood his
Elementary School buried a time capsule
48 years ago it'll be opened in two
years what would you put in a time
capsule to show your sons oh I like this
question
um you know I was thinking about it
before I do a quick scan of the
questions before we do this
um you know it would be kind of funny to
put a original game boy in there the
original black and white Game Boy which
I think came out in probably give me a
year I'm gonna guess it's around
1988 87 something like that I remember
getting that game boy the week it came
out and it was black and white it was
kind of big and bulky you had to put
four double a batteries in there it came
with a Mario game and of course oh no it
came with Tetris uh but then there of
course was also a Super Mario game came
out in 89 okay uh so a couple years
after 8-bit NES Nintendo Entertainment
System but I think that would be a great
thing to put in a time capsule because
for for me of a Gen X generation you
know a child of the 80s that was the
first like handheld thing we had like
little little very LED or what was it
LED or the the black and the purely
black and white ones where you could
press like up or down kind of things but
Game Boy was the first one that you
could sort of move on the go with video
games and compare that to having the
world in our pocket right now like what
what an absolute Time Warp that would be
to show to uh to show to my kids and in
48 years or so uh Quinn says if you
could label each quarter of 2023 ahead
of time what words themes or hopes might
you think of I think it's going to be
something like this
I think this first quarter is going to
be a lot more exposure of the nonsense
right we're in the midst of the exposure
of the nonsense that and that's really
sort of how we were ending 2022 that the
Twitter files are coming out we're
finding out more about what they did
related to covid and the hunter Biden
laptop and all of those things but then
what happens is you get a certain amount
of that and then you get a certain
amount of pushback so I think it's going
to be sort of a cyclical this strikes me
as a year of a lot of forward movement
and a lot of backwards movement which
maybe when you add them up you just kind
of don't move at all but I think the
first quarter of this will be a
continuation of the exposure of the
nonsense and Elon has already hinted now
that the fauci files are about to drop
too as I keep saying related to all of
this the real question is okay if you
see the the fauci files and it and it
emboldens or it strengthens your world
view related to all of this and the
nonsense that these pushed that these
people push that's great but is it
affecting anyone on the other side of
this is it affecting the NPCs is it
waking up anyone else is it is it
changing the minds of anyone that only
watches mainstream media I don't know
and and that Divergence between the
people who will see reality out how it
is and the people who will see the
reality that they paint for them I don't
know how you mitigate those two things I
think that's going to be a big thing but
anyway to answer your question so I
think it's going to be a quarterly sort
of exposure second quarter pushback on
exposure third quarter more exposure
fourth quarter pushback on that and as I
said maybe that just kind of leaves us
exactly where we are right now which
maybe isn't that bad right as opposed to
being dragged the other direction
Delaney says I just finished your book I
have to admit that I enjoyed the last
half more because you talk so much about
your life and how you achieve so much I
feel very inspired to take a risk with
starting a career that means something
to me I would love to read a book that
is more of an autobiography I would love
to hear about your parents and
grandparents and how you grew up with
your family when is the next book coming
so I have a couple ideas for the next
book and and just in the last because we
had a week off and although we had a lot
of family here it was the holidays and
everything I started sketching out the
beginnings of what I think will be my my
third book
um and when I wrote the first two books
we actually especially in don't burn
this book which was the first book
obviously I had way more related to my
family it started becoming more of an
autobiography and when I was talking to
my editor about it
her feeling and she's really great Helen
if you're watching I love you uh she not
Helen my former assistant I had a
different Ellen uh at the time she kept
saying that you know really for your
first book you want to you want to go
idea heavy so that more and more people
can find out about your ideas and then
eventually you'd go more autobiography
heavy so we did a little bit more in
don't burn this country related to my
family and I talk a bit about my
grandparents and my parents and sort of
you know my family really is I think the
perfect example of the American dream it
was my great great grandparents on one
side and Grandpa great grandparents on
my dad's side who came to this country
everybody had nothing came from Eastern
Europe I mean it's literally the the
story with the suitcase and nothing else
my grandfather who was one of six uh
brothers and sisters whose father died
when he was two months old and they
lived in a one-bedroom room uh on the
Lower East Side and then when his father
died when he was two months they had to
move in with his aunt and uncle and then
it was literally like 15 people in a
two-bedroom apartment you know lower you
know lower lower class but fighting for
the American dream and then my
grandfather got his first job which I
think if I'm not mistaken paid him a
quarter an hour or something like that
and uh and he was a lithographer and
then he got eventually married my
grandmother who was the first woman on
her side to go to college and she became
a teacher then my parents became middle
class obviously we're doing pretty well
and it's like that is the American dream
that the generations behind you will do
better than you did and that's what
we're at the risk of giving away because
of these ridiculous economic policies
and just the general buffoonery of the
people involved in the decision making
these days so yes I I should explore a
little bit uh more of that and I will
keep that in mind and uh on a personal
note go do it take some risks why not
like just do it just do it and see what
it happens that was always my premise my
entire life when I was doing stand-up
and everything I was doing I was like if
you gave everything you have to
something
could the nature of reality be that you
will just be screwed in the process I
don't really think so I think if you
really really go for something you might
not get exactly that thing but you'll
get something kind of in that
constellation and that probably is good
enough Spike says we know you love
basketball how do you feel about Golf
and have you tried Sporting Clays or
Trapper skeet okay so yes I'm a
basketball guy and I'm playing again
which is great with my three braces on
my knees and a couple weeks ago most of
the guys that I play with they're like
it's probably upper 20s 30s 40s into 50s
I'm like right in the middle at 46 a
couple weeks ago one of the guys who's
you know about my age he brought his
sons from his son from college with his
friends so it was the 21 year olds
versus the old dudes and we split the
games with them I hit a game-winning
jumper so I'm feeling good on that front
uh I'm not much of a golfer go golf
driving every now and again but David
actually is a great golfer and he was a
golfer in uh in high school and we have
a little putting green in the backyard
so we will get the kids playing golf for
sure and I have not gone on Skeet
shooting at you know we're going
shooting down here in Florida we'll
shoot some stuff but have not done the
skeet shooting yet although I was pretty
good at Duck Hunt back in the day I was
pretty pretty pretty good uh soos says
we need to stop allowing the left to own
the language they lost in some ways on
don't say gay but not entirely it's a
good example of their effectiveness when
it comes to communication Republicans
are awful in this regard a critical
action item when delivering a message or
a vision how do we Corral that effort
that is a great point
one of the things that Democrats do
really well because they own the machine
right so they they own not only the
corporate press which frames everything
from the the direction that they want it
framed but now we also know that they've
had all this collusion with big Tech so
certain things Trend the way they want
them to to Trend and then whatever
Republicans or conservatives or whatever
you want to call it whatever they want
to get out there doesn't fly as much and
then I think the other problem that
Republicans have or or right-leaning
people whatever you want to say it is is
that because there is a little more
reality there reality is a little harder
to explain to people rather than just
baseless sort of generic statements so
like don't say gay just sounds like
something and a certain amount of people
just believe don't say gay I can't say
gay what am I gonna do and then and then
that's it right that's a lot easier to
sell to people than trying to calmly
explain to them what individual rights
are and what parental rights are and the
role of government in education and
everything else so that's why I think we
always end up on our back foot they
throw out some crazy bomb you're racist
and then you have to spend all day
explaining why you're not racist so
that's what needs to shift so another
example of this just from last week
would be that right during Christmas uh
Rand Paul Senator Rand Paul from
Kentucky he always puts out his Festivus
list of like the craziest governmental
spending and he puts out this long
Twitter thread and it's really fantastic
he did a funny a funny video that I
shared a couple a couple weeks ago
it's a lot harder to explain all of this
and make people read this stuff and go
boy the government did spend a lot a lot
on this and wasted on that rather than
just the nonsense that they throw at us
so so you know what I did give a speech
what was it about about three weeks ago
now I went to DC and I spoke to all the
new Congressional Republicans and I
talked to them about messaging I talked
to them about not apologizing my main
point was bring receipts like Ted Cruz
did on The View you know don't just sit
back and take it but when they when they
say well you know Donald Trump and you
Republicans are our election deniers do
what Ted Cruz did bring out the receipts
guys here's Hillary Clinton here's
Stacey Abrams here's all of the people
when it was Bush Gore et cetera Etc do
that and try to get some of those clips
to go viral that that really is the key
uh Ray says what did Santa bring you you
know Santa Ana Annika Annika Harry
Hanukkah Harry they were uh they were a
little light on me this year I really
have everything that I wanted at a at a
sort of physical tangible level you know
we had such a good year at the kids so
it was more about getting stuff for the
kids and really at their age like what
do they need they need diapers and milk
that's pretty much it uh I got a couple
bottles of nice tequila that's all I did
I really didn't want I truly did not
want anything we went to a couple great
parties and and family was here and that
was really good enough for me uh Lloyd
says Times Square has the ball drop
Boise has the potato drop how did you
celebrate New Year's Eve in Miami since
we heard they canceled the neon orange
ah that there should be some sort of
giant orange ball dropping from uh
Florida somewhere uh we went to a
fantastic uh party up in Miami Beach and
a lot a lot of old friends were there
some new friends some some friends of
the show and just had a absolutely great
night I did not get home till about 3 30
a.m because the traffic leaving Miami
Beach on New Year's was completely
bananas uh but it was uh yeah we just
had we just had a great it was great to
get out too because obviously in these
last couple months we don't get out that
often you know I travel a little bit but
uh David is is in the thick of it with
the kids so this was maybe our since
August it was maybe our third night out
uh together so that was uh that was a
lot of fun uh vika says I'm interested
in doing a two-week Off the Grid
vacation with my daughters seven and six
years old and maybe my husband I'd like
some tips do you go full on no Tech I go
grocery shop watch movies listen to
music keep in touch with my family all
on my phone should I also cut out those
things do you have you changed your
strategy Through The Years I'd
appreciate some suggestions so first off
the fact that you're even considering
doing this I love it and I know many
more people
I've been doing it when I do this off
the uh grid August situation and and
it's really wonderful so uh in the in
years past I literally did it like phone
locked in a safe no Twitter no email
absolutely nothing David kinda does it
with me but he did have a phone it
wasn't his regular phone it was like an
old iPhone that was disconnected from
everything with no apps on it just in
case there was an emergency so that you
know his mom could basically get in
touch with us that kind of thing this
past year was different because uh
Justin was about to be born and we knew
we had to be in touch obviously with the
surrogate and the doctor and family
members who were going to come visit us
and that sort of thing so we were a
little more connected this time I was
you know people were texting me
congratulations I was responding back
and forth but I was not doing email or
Twitter or anything else I would say you
got to figure out something that works
for you like you could do it like
completely cold turkey meaning no
television like no nothing that's tough
especially if you have seven and six
years six year olds but if you just at
the very least get rid of social media
tell people tell your family and friends
hey give give us two weeks here where
don't just don't don't call us unless
it's an emergency don't text us unless
it's an emergency and I would say also
like a simple version of it would be
wherever you go with them and whatever
you try to do try to just not take your
phone you know if you're just going out
for a couple hours even it's not that at
the end of the day you can't just look
and just make sure everything's okay
with life that's like the extreme
version of it and trust me it really is
worth it if you can ever afford yourself
the time and space to do it but just
like you know if you're going out for a
hike just just no phone you're going
wherever you're going you're going to
lunch just no phone and I think that it
will really help the reset and uh I wish
you a lot of luck keep me keep me posted
Elizabeth says can we expect another
comedy special anytime soon don't say
Dave was hilarious thank you very much
by the way if you want to watch don't
say Dave which was the unedited portion
of my talk which it's mostly it's kind
of stand up and a lot of silly stuff and
some stories and blah blah blah it's
about 40 40 45 minutes or so it is free
for all annual local subscribers so
reubenreport.locals.com and you get it
absolutely free or you can buy it one
off I think it's 9.99 if I'm not
mistaken
um you know I gotta get back out on the
road really to kind of figure figure
that out which
I don't know how much Road stuff I'm
going to be doing this year because of
the kids I think we're going to do one
big international trip that we're trying
to put together a couple weeks in May
where we're going to bounce around
Europe and maybe the Middle East and
figure out a few things there but I
would like to do another special maybe a
little more maybe maybe a little more
traditionally stand up special where the
way I do it for those of you that have
seen my shows you know I'm doing a lot
of this stuff off the cuff I'm messing
with the crowd it's it's really like
it's juggling up there without even
knowing how many balls you're juggling
just kind of figuring it out and that's
like the messy fun part for me I maybe
would do something that would be a
little bit more scripted uh but but
we'll see we got a lot on the plate at
the moment uh Steve says Dave what do
you think top five issues for 2023 will
be for our good old USA first half of
the Year versus last half or latter half
well that's sort of similar to the
question earlier I mean I really think I
think the main issue is the information
War at this point like we know that the
government is not going to stop big
spending we know that this whatever is
going on with Ukraine is going to be
ramped up we know that when they want to
scare you with covet they'll scare you
with covet
we know all that stuff and that stuff
just ain't stopping right uh we also
know that you know people just kind of
vote the wrong way they really do right
the the midterms did not go the way that
we would have liked although actually
the Republicans are in charge of uh the
house right now in charge of Congress so
that is good so there are some good
markers here but I think the main thing
is just going to be this battle for your
mind like this true information War
where some of us will believe
what I believe to be closer to the truth
and and understand the messiness of that
and understand that what they call
misinformation isn't misinformation just
because they call it that and and
figuring out like how do you how do you
actually uh live in a society where
people will
fundamentally believe different things
which will be very different than say 40
years ago when when a liberal and a
conservative of 40 years ago believe
different things they believe that
reality basically was the same right
that that you had that layer was kind of
the same like the United States is
pretty good here you know there was a
basic understanding of what human
freedom is and all those things and then
the real battle was like oh but I want
the government to do more or I want the
government to do less now now the
reality is literally like do you think
chopping off kids genitals is good yes
or no do you think that there should be
governments above the government of the
United States do you think you should
hand over all of your personal
responsibility or not do you think that
the core corporate press that has lied
about all of these things
is going to stop lying I don't know how
you mitigate those things I think in
your own personal life you can do it by
surrounding yourself with good
like-minded people and figuring out ways
to build things together but at the
Machine level I just don't know what you
do about that but we'll continue to try
to figure it out cecito says happy New
Year any tips for a dry January my liver
needs a break after the holidays well
look you could re well one thing you
want to try uh January just just cut off
the booze just do it easy enough Do It
um look you guys know my feelings I like
tequila I like going to parties we like
hosting a lot of dinners and all that
sort of stuff but then I always try to
take a couple days off here and there
sometimes I'll take a week off you know
I'm rarely accepted some of the parties
although I could get in trouble for
saying this I'm not that wasted that
often well our holiday party I guess
that was kind of under the table but
generally speaking you know what I mean
but I I do enjoy sipping tequila but
this is a good month like January is a
good month it just kind of ease up like
after December and parties and family
and all of the food and all the cakes
and all the stuff this is a good month I
would say one other thing which I always
try to do it's gotten a little bit more
difficult with the kids now is we always
used to start our day with a nice long
walk with Clyde for a couple miles in
the morning and I'd be going through the
show while while I was doing it
sometimes trying not to take my phone
but it is what it is sometimes we take
the kids now sometimes we can't just
because schedules are offer naps or
whatever it is but if I think if you
start your day with a walk just a simple
lock you don't have to do crazy cardio
you don't have to be in the gym going
dripping with sweat but starting the day
with the walk like let your body just
kind of
do its thing a little bit of water to
start the day I think that helps and
then and then if you want to have the
cocktail once twice a week I I
personally I don't think it's that big
of a deal uh Richard says do you feel
more energized and motivated now
compared to any other time in your life
I just retired and I feel more
optimistic about being in control of my
life as well as the journey forward than
ever before well first off congrats on
your retirement it is uh you know when
people work for you know 40 50 years and
then ultimately retire what what an
incredible moment that is my dad retired
after about 45 years of work 40 of those
years at the same company going into New
York City I talk about this in in Doper
in this book going into New York City
commuting on the Long Island Railroad
basically an hour each way five days a
week for 40 years I added up the year
the the time on that and it turned out
to be something like two full years of
his life just commuting to go to work
and and now he's retired and there's
always that moment of people retiring
what am I going to do right now and do I
volunteer do I devote my life to the
grandkids blah blah blah so first off I
I wish you a lot of luck with that and
and it's it's awesome that you you work
hard and now you're feeling good about
things going forward as far as me and
energize and all that yeah I do I you
know like even this morning when I was
sitting with Phoenix and Connor I was
like man we all like what we do and that
makes you want to get up and do it and
do a better job and and build better
things and all that stuff and now I have
a family too a bigger family than I had
let's say a couple months back and like
I want to keep building good things for
them so I feel very energized I wake up
I guess that's one thing I've been very
blessed with but I but it maybe is just
a function of my work too is that I wake
up I have something to do
something to do that I want to do and I
guess a lot of people don't do that
they're afraid to find whatever that is
or it hasn't worked out or they've got
whatever their stuff is and they they
just haven't gone in that direction but
I really believe it like go that
direction and see what happens and as I
said before even if you don't fully get
to that thing something else along the
way will uh will work itself out that
that will be pretty good I really
believe that Purdue says what happened
to the people who used to want to work
oh this is a funny follow-up question
everyone seems to want to hire but no
one seems to want a job I don't
understand how I got into this situation
please comment I'm sure I'm not the only
person wondering well first off what are
you hiring for because maybe we can help
you out with the locals Community I know
we've helped a couple people connect
with getting jobs we've had a couple
people that have connected at least one
set of people that got married in the
locals Community like we've had a lot of
good stuff going on in there so what are
you trying to hire for but yeah that is
a huge issue I mean I remember when we
were leaving La that those last few
months in La where every store
everywhere the ones that weren't boarded
up and destroyed and demolished they had
now hiring and they had 15 an hour and
extra benefits and all that stuff and
yet they could not get anybody to work
there you'd go into a diner or whatever
it might be and service was slow because
they couldn't get servers we don't see
as much of that here in Florida there
does seem to be a really really you know
functioning economy and I think there's
a million reasons for that related to
low taxes and just a certain Juan de V
that makes people want to actually do
things here we're in these other places
you know once you once you buy into that
ideology that the government's supposed
to give you stuff it's hard to get up
you know it's it's hard to get up oh boy
the government's been giving me a lot of
stuff let me get up and go do something
for my own and lose the stuff that the
government's been giving me it's it's
human nature to just want stuff and
that's what they're preying on with a
certain set of people so when did people
lose that will to work well I think I
think the system has really
well I guess if you want a year I guess
it's around 72 or 73 when the welfare
state exploded we started giving all of
these benefits to a certain set of
people it it actually harmed the family
this has nothing to do with skin color
directly it would have happened to
anyone that had been given these things
and now a whole generation has grown up
thought oh I will just get stuff by the
nature of my existence and and that is
not good it ain't good Lori says what
are your primary goals for the new year
professional and personal I would say on
the professional note uh you know we
really set ourselves up well in the last
year we we worked really hard we had by
far every month we were crushing our
numbers across platforms obviously there
is a ton going on in the rumble locals
ecosystem which I've hinted at a little
bit and we'll have a lot more to uh to
explain and and share with you over over
the coming weeks and months but I think
we've set ourselves really up really
nicely to be I would say a leading voice
of how about independent sanity right I
make the decisions around here what
comes out of my mouth is what I believe
For Better or For Worse I'm gonna you
know I think I think one thing that I'm
very proud of
is that if you look at my track record
over the last couple years I got the big
stuff right now I may have got political
predictions wrong like I definitely
thought the Red Wave was coming but
political predictions that's just like
you just don't know what's gonna happen
that you leave that up to fickle voters
and people who are misinformed and all
that stuff so okay you can get
predictions wrong but like when it came
to covid and mandates and all of those
things like I got that right when it
came to the hunter Biden laptop and what
was going on with the election and are
we allowed to ask questions I got that
right the the big trending things I
think I got right and I think that's
really that's why we say if you if you
stayed roughly sane then you're pretty
good so that's really what I just want
to continue to do I want to take the
principles that I believe in that I
think I can communicate in a decent way
and keep getting them out there and see
what happens and hopefully get a few
more other people you guys to continue
to wake up apply those things in your
life and then not need that machine that
never-ending sucking monster machine uh
to to be part of what we do it'll always
be there right it'll always be there as
I said like we can expose it for a
certain degree and then it always pushes
back I don't know what that is but like
that's sort of
how reality works I guess
um but I just want to keep keep building
this uh keep working with people that I
want to work with keep expanding what
we're doing here keep growing having
more influence and and seeing does that
play into National politics like what
does that actually lead to we'll see and
on a personal note I mean it's fairly
obvious I really just want to be the
best father that I can be which you know
at the stage we're at right now before
crawling before talking like it's mostly
just keeping these kids alive and
keeping them you know I love going
downstairs in the morning and you know
just like getting everybody Smiley and
happy and ready for the day and and
feeding them and all that stuff
um But continuing as they start growing
and and as their brains I just watched
this documentary last night about uh the
the uh the child's brain and like how
much is happening and how it's such a
super sponge for information and emotion
right now and all these things like I
want to keep doing the best I can to
make sure that what we're putting out in
the world there are two kids who are
ready to to take this world on and apply
hopefully the things that that I talk
about here in their own lives and and
live a life that's way cooler than mine
wouldn't that be something uh Monique
says Viva fry you mentioned having a
locals meet up in 2023 any chance of a
combined Meetup since you guys are both
in South Florida yes absolutely I'll
talk to Viva about that but you know
we've got our great Florida crew here
with Lisa booth and John cardillo and
Carol Markowitz and Josh Hammer the
whole crew maybe I'll get everybody
together we'll do a big locals Meetup uh
which we we did we've only done one in
Miami so far
and it was before I even moved to Miami
so we got to do it it was a very busy
year and it's uh my my windows of like
oh let's go do something they're just
getting smaller and smaller but I will
absolutely keep that in mind we'll get
we'll get viva's community involved too
and I'm just thrilled that Viva you guys
know Viva who's a great lawyer and now
now rumbler and YouTuber communicating a
lot of the ideas that I'm talking about
and a Canada Refugee we are very happy
to have him uh down here in Florida I
should tell you before we rap guys that
this episode has been pre-taped I
pre-taped this yesterday on the second
because right now as I am airing this I
am actually at Governor desantis's
Inauguration in Tallahassee it's
happening right at this very moment for
me tomorrow for you right now uh and
there was a there's a big ball uh this
evening so hopefully I'll be able to get
some video and see who else is there and
maybe we can play some of that stuff
over the next couple days uh anyway yes
I'm Phil feeling good about the start of
the Year I hope you are as well as
always subscribe at rumble.com
reubenreport and if you want to play
along and submit questions and see
pictures of the babies and just get a
little more intimate uh with me and what
we do here as a team and just everything
we're kind of building please do join us
at Ruben report.locals.com and we leave
you with
Kamala Harris adios